hello I have two types pepper let's see
how badly these make me sneeze the here
we go this is a requested video trying
to sneeze whilst reading this is the
topless video that was supposed to
pester topi is satisfy - you thought so
we hope you enjoyed it
spoiler alert this is a sex thing the
kid with a serious case of the sniffles
is Thomas from Wales England sickly
little inbred cousin he pays the bills
making custom sneeze vids so pervs can
snot in their pants sneezing is your
body's way of telling your girlfriend
she needs to put her cat down it's the
one time you get to hand out blessings
like the Pope without the burden of
apologizing for centuries of pedophilia
only atheists and Nazis say gesundheit
and if you use more than twice in a row
in public I should be allowed to slap
you right in the face like releasing any
bodily fluid it feels amazing but it's
traumatic if someone else's lands on you
the fact that they had to install sneeze
guards at salad bars means there was a
time when our parents would blow nose
loads right in the goddamn cube damn but
I can't blame Thomas for figuring out
how to turn a sneeze into cheese that's
why I put him on a choo-choo train to
hollywood for this week's ce-web-rity
profile
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Thomas sneeze to meet you get it
little nasal humor for you
hey Daniel I know you're on this show oh
yeah anywhere there's stage time heard
this crowds hot where are you from from
Wales I don't know a lot about Wales
their second language is Welch else yeah
I can speak a bit of Welsh yet these
horrendous words are come out it sounds
like a sneeze almost yes some doses I
know how long the flight was it to fly
from Wales to Los Angeles it's about 11
hour flight we were scheduled to do this
interview and then what did you do to
completely ruin everyone's day so I've
got an allergy and I ate a regular it
was nice but has also got walnuts and
then about ten minutes later I start
swelling up were you terrified at first
I was trying to keep calm and just sort
of right I was sort of scary do you feel
were liable no we've never had a guest
on this show died we've had guests on
the show and then they later died you
would have gone down in history how did
you get involved in sneezing 2014 I
decide to write every day of the year
I'm gonna make a video and someone said
are there any videos of you sneezing no
so I was like why not I might as well
can you sneeze it will know are you a
one-off or do you do too or the Annoying
three people I hate the three sneezers
it's usually one do you think it's
bizarre yes it definitely is videos I
always do well my channel it's when I
sneeze in bed I mean my PJs like ell and
you look like a little boy to kinda do
you think it's sexual I got into
sneezing myself I just make the videos
but yeah that's definitely the fattest
side
what's the strangest requests you've
ever had from a fan sneezing into a
snorkeling mask how do you make yourself
sneeze use this pink tea powder stuff
well chink nee gini chink Nick yeah
sounds racist
it's a Indian herbal remedy okay so it
is racist so you're supposed to sniff it
sniffing just massive sneezing feds do
you have any of that chick knee powder
on you yes I do
oh now it's a green room I brought this
and what do you do
so use the aisle just that's a lot the
first time you did it were you satisfied
with the results but I doubt the first
time I did that was just well this is my
first time probably not like I said that
before leaning over a table alright it's
pretty strong stuff yeah I'm gonna do
that bless you do you think you'll keep
doing this for a long time possibly
audience requests keep coming in he'll
keep you or your family are they
supportive and they know a bit is there
any request that you won't do I totally
have like a no news here oh what's the
most in a row I don't know this is quite
a good trend at the moment they say
sneezing is one eighth of an orgasm
we pads quite the right than just now
make you a sneezing whore I mean I
appeal to people's Factor shares my good
internet so technically I am a webcam
model
how long does like a bump of that last
three five minutes usually what I'll do
is would have a shower afterwards to get
everything out that sounds fun real you
in a nice warm shower afterwards alright
Thomas you're up next you better bring
your A game because this opening act is
a real yawnfest
mmm alright that's my time thank you
ladies gentlemen tonight I am going to
attempt the world's first open eyed
knees shirtless
[Applause]
sometimes it takes a minute yarn guy you
watch this
he's got sneeze fright please sneeze you
tease clean next it's coming
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you thank you what a talent
they worthless talent all right who's
ready for some of my famous joint
cracking that's right I just blew that
man boy in from Wales to talk about
sneezing what do you want for me we've
been on the air for all 11 years
you